[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصاد الليله معكم عثمان اي
فرح وفي الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تتفاعلوا
احداث وتقع اخرى هذه الصور من الجابون
البلد الافريقي الذي يعيش على وقع انقلاب
اخر في القاره الافريقيه اليوم ادى قائد
الانقلاب اليمين رئيسا انتقاليا وهذه
الصور من ميامي ترقب بالتطورات بشان وجود
القاعده الفرنسيه والسفير الفرنسي بعد
الانقلاب في النيجر وفي مواضيع الحصاد هذه
الليله
الضفه الغربيه مساحه تصعيد متجدد
قوات الاحتلال تقتحم جنين على وقع
اشتباكات وتعلن اعتقال اثنين من مقاتلي
القسام وقيادي في حماس والفصائل تستهدف
اليات الاحتلال بتفجير عبوات الناسفه
واقرار اسرائيلي باسقاط مسيره بالجيش
في تحركات اقليميه متزامنه البرهان في جبا
في ثاني زيارته الخارجيه منذ بدء المعارك
وحمايه يتهمه بالتسبب في اندلاع الازمه
وبعد لقاء مسؤول بالدعم السريع مع رئيس
مفوضيه الاتحاد الافريقي الخارجيه
السودانيه تندد وتصف اللقاء بالسابقه
الخطيره
[موسيقى]
وفي الجابون فتره انتقاليه بلا مده محدده
قائد الحرس الجمهوري يؤدي اليمين رئيسا
ويعد بتسليم الحكم بعد انتخابات حره
والمجموعه الاقتصاديه لوسط افريقيا تفرض
عقوبات وتعلق عضويه الجابون وتقول ان
الانقلاب مصدر تهديد لدولها
قمه روسيه تركيه في سوتشي دون اختراقات
لاحياء اتفاق تصدير الحبوب بوتين يحدد رفع
العقوبات شرطا للعوده للاتفاق اردوغان
يكشف عن تحضير حزمه مقترحات بشراكه امميه
تتهم موسكو بابتزاز المجتمع الدولي
في لقائنا اليومي قبل الحصاد ناقشنا على
منصاتنا الرقميه مسلسل الاقتحامات
الاسرائيليه المستمره في جنين حيث اعلنت
اسرائيل اليوم اعتقال اثنين من مقاتلي
القسام وقيادي في حماس هناك هذه التطوراته
جاءت على وقع اشتباكات مع مقاتلي الفصائل
الذين قالوا انهم استهدفوا اليات لجيش
الاحتلال وفجروا عبوات ناسفه فيها
لاستطلاع ارائكم بشان هذا الموضوع كنا قد
طرحنا عليكم السؤال التالي في اي سياق
ياتي تصاعد واستمرار عمليات قوات الاحتلال
في الضفه الغربيه
35 في المئه قالوا ان هذه العمليات تاتي
في اطار سياسه تصاعديه اسرائيليه بينما
اعتبر 48% ان ما يحدث ما هو سوى ترحيل
ازمات الحكومه بينما قال 17% ان هذه
العمليات جاءت ردا على تطور العمل
الفصائلي
هذا السؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا
الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر
مسح رمز كيو ار الظاهره على الشاشه لقائنا
على المنصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا ونتطرق
خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله عربيا
ودوليا
[موسيقى]
على هذه التطورات في جنين اعدت جيفارا
البديري التقرير التعليم
قوه من الوحدات الخاصه التابعه لقوات
الاحتلال تسللت الى حي الغبه عند اطراف
مخيم جنين
اكتشفها المقاومون
القوات الاحتلال بتعزيزات تزيد على اربعين
اليه
اندلعت اشتباكات المسلحه
جنود الاحتلال النشر القناصه حول منزلا
تخفى به عبد الله الصبح ومعتصم جعاي ساور
دشريم وهم مقاومون من كتائب القسامات ذراع
المسلح لحركه حماس
طلبهم الجنود بالاستسلام رفضوا حاولوا
الهرب الا ان الجنود اطلقوا النار عليهم
اقتحموا المنزل الذي تحصل به المقاومون
الثلاثه قبل اعتقالهم وعاتوا فيه فساد
والى رفع سلاح بوجهه بحكي الوقف وقف وقف
وين الشباب وين سلاح وين شبكه الفش عنا
شباب فش عنا سلاح شو بدك انت قاعدين احنا
بنشتغل وانت شايف دارنا
وقفني فوتني على غرفه وحجزني بالغرفه
صاروا يفتشوا بالشقه فوق تبعت ابني قواته
الاحتلال نقلت المقاتلين من بينهم جريحان
بمروحيه عسكريه قرب معبر الجلم العسكري
كتائب القسام وكتيبه جنين وكتائب الاقصى
اكدت ان العمليه لن تكسره المقاومه
العمليه العسكريه الاسرائيليه الاخيره
تاتي في ظل تصعيدا متواصل في الضفه
الغربيه يستهدف القرى والبلدات والمخيمات
كما تستهدف الاسرى في سجون الاحتلال ان
المتوقع ان تستمر قوات الاحتلال في اللجوء
لهذه العمليات لانها توقع خسائر اقل في
صفوف الاحتلال اولا ولا تؤدي الى وقوع
مجازر في صفوف الفلسطينيين بما قد يؤدي
الى تصعيد اكثر للوضع المتصاعد اصلا
المواجهات المستمره بين الفلسطينيين وقوات
الاحتلال ادت منذ مطلع العام الى مقتل 36
مستوطنا وجنديا كما استشهد
فلسطينيه عمليه عسكريه جديده في جنين لا
ينفصل سياقها او توقيتها عن عمليات سابقه
بالض فه الغربيه يبعث الاحتلال من خلالها
رسائل الى الداخل الاسرائيلي استعراض
للقوه يقابله الفلسطينيون بمزيد من
المقاومه
والاستبسال الجزيره من مخيم جنين
وفي ردود الفعل قال مصدر في كتائب القسام
في جنين الجزيره ان الاحتلال فشل في تحقيق
هدفه من اقتحام مخيم الجنين واضاف ان
عناصر القسام اكتشفوا القوه الخاصه
واشتبكوا معها وافشل والهدف الرئيسيه
للاحتلال حسب قوله كما قال المصدر ان
الايام ستثبت ان عمليه الاقتحام فشلت وان
الاعتقالات لن توقف المقاومه في الضفه
الغربيه
وقالت حركه حماس ان عناصر كتائب القسام في
مخيم جنين افشلوا اليوم مخطط لاحتلال
للنيل من المقاومه واضافت الحركه في بيان
ان الاشتباكات الضاريه التي خاضها
المقاومون اليوم شكلت ملحمه بطوليه ورساله
للعدو واكد البيان ان اعتقال اثنين من
عناصر القسام لن يفت في عضد المقاومين
الذين لا ترهبهم الملاحقات والاعتقالات
وفق البيانات
وقالت كتيبه جنينه تابعه لسرايا القدس
الجناح العسكري لحركه الجهاد الاسلامي
انها رصد التسلل قوات خاصه اسرائيليه على
اطراف مخيم جنين واضافت ان عناصرها استهدف
القوه المتسلله بالرصاص كما اشتبكوا معها
بشكل مباشر وكشفت الكتيبه انها تمكنت من
اسقاط طائره مسيره تابعه للاحتلال وسيطرت
عليها واوضحت انها تمكنت من استهداف اماكن
تمركز قناصه الاحتلال في المكان
من رام الله ينضم الينا ساريه عرابي
الكاتب والباحث السياسي اهلا بك كيف تقرا
التطور الذي يعني يشهده الوضع الميداني في
الضفه الغربيه
من الواضح تماما ان الضفه الغربيه باتت
ساحه مواتيه اكثر من اي وقت ماضي منذ
نهايه انتفاضه الاقصى حتى هذه اللحظه من
اجل استئناف العمل المقاوم في الضفه
الغربيه اعتقد ان هذه المشهديه المتكرره
والمستمره من الحاله الكفاحيه التي تاخذ
بالتكرس اكثر في الضفه الغربيه ناجمه عن
مجموعه من العوامل من اهم هذه العوامل
سلسله الهبات التي ظلت تتوالى في الضفه
الغربيه في السنوات الاخيره منذ العام
2014 كذلك هبت العام 2015 و17 و19 طبعا
كان الحدث الحاسم والمفصل الذي نقل الضفه
الغربيه نقله كبيره الى الامام هي معركه
سيف القدس في العام 2021 حينما لفت
الفلسطينيين حاله كفاحيه واحده في كل مكان
في الضفه الغربيه في الكورس في الاراضي
المحتله عام 48 بالاضافه طبعا لحاله
المقاومه داخل قطاع غزه بالاضافه الى
الادوار المتعدده التي قام بها
الفلسطينيون خارج الارض المحتله كذلك ما
يسمى بالعمليات الفرديه او عامل العمليات
ذاتيه الدافع التي تكثفت طبعا اواخر العام
2015 وظلت مستمره حتى هذه اللحظه ايضا
شكلت حاله من الالهام والتوليد لاعمال
مقاومه اخرى كذلك نماذج التشكيلات المسلحه
في شماليه الضفه الغربيه ارض التشكيل
المسلح الموجود في مخيم جنين وكذلك ظاهره
عرين الاسود في نابلس خلقت محاولات من
المحاكاه تمددت الى مناطق متعدده ايضا
داخل الضفه الغربيه كذلك الجهد الذي ظلت
تقوم به وتدفع نحوه فصائل المقاومه في
الضفه الغربيه مثل حركه حماس ومثل حركه
الجهاد الاسلامي العديد من المحاولات
والشهداء والاسرى والخلايا التي ظلت تعمل
في السنوات الاخيره من اجل استئناف حاله
المكون في الضفه الغربيه طبعا لا يمكن ان
نفصل ذلك نعم تفضل فقط دعنا اخساري نتابع
معا كيف تغير مشهد الاشتباكات المسلحه في
الضدفه الغربيه خلال العامين الماضيين
نتابع تقرير صهيب العصا ثم نتابع النقاش
اي مواجهه في الضفه الغربيه بين اسرائيل
والمقاومه الفلسطينيه بعد اعوام من
محاولات تجفيف المنابع وشبه اختفاء كامل
للعمل المسلح اعادت المقاومه في الضفه رسم
المشهد من جديد يمكن القول ان العمل
المسلح هناك ينقسم الى نوعين عمليات فرديه
واخرى جماعيه العمليات الفرديه ينفذها شخص
او اثنان ليس اكثر عاده ما تكون عمليات
طعن او اطلاق نار في مكان محدد تنتهي
بالاعتقال او القتل يحصل المنفذون على
اسلحتهم بطريقه شخصيه عبر شرائه من تجار
السلاح او قد يكون السلاح سكينا من المنزل
في النوع الثاني نتحدث عن الخلايا وتلك
اما تابعه لفصائل معروفه واجنحتها
العسكريه او تشكيلات عسكريه جديده كحاله
عرين الاسود التي لا ينتمي مقاتلوها الى
اي من الفصائل المعروفه ينفذ هؤلاء
المقاتلون عمليه اطلاق نار النقاط
الاسرائيليه المنتشره في الضفه او يصنعون
عبوات ناسفه او يتصدون الاقتحامات جيش
الاحتلال هذه الاشكال من المقاومه تحتاج
الى تخطيط وتمويل وتسليح وتوفير
اللوجستيات اللازمه للمقاتلين وعملياتهم
عاده ما تحصل هذه الخلايا على السلاح من
مصادر مختلفه احدها التهريب من الحدود
وتحديدا الحدود الاردنيه مع الضفه الغربيه
هذا امر يؤرق اسرائيل اذ نتحدث عن 97
كيلومترا من الحدود من ضمنها البحر الميت
الذي شهد عمليات تهريب واسعه خلال
الانتفاضه الثانيه على تلك الحدود تعلن
اسرائيل بين فينه واخرى ضبطها عمليه تهريب
ولكنها بلا شك تفشل في عمليات اخرى لذلك
قال نتنياهو ان حكومته تسعى لبناء سياجا
على تلك الحدود كذلك الذي بنته على الحدود
مع مصر تدخل الاموال والاسلحه كذلك مصادر
اخرى منها فلسطينيون الخط الاخضر او تجار
الاسلحه الاسرائيليون الذين لا يهمهم الا
المال بالدرجه الاساسيه لا تزال اسرائيل
تبحث في كل مره عن كل تفصيله تفيدها في
وقف هذا العمل لكنها على الارض تواجه
مقاومه لها اذرعها ووسائلها المختلفه لا
تخفي الفصائل الفلسطينيه وقوفها وراء كثير
من ذلك العمل بل تهدد بالمزيد تلك رساله
يكرر قاده في الفصائل التاكيد عليها وهي
الاعلان عن التنسيق المشترك للعمل المسلح
في الضفه الغربيه من هذه الرسائل ظهور
نائب رئيس المكتب السياسي لحركه حماس صالح
العروري بلباس عسكري للمره الاولى مباشره
بعد ساعات من تهديد نتنياهو له بالاغتيال
متهما اياهم بالوقوف وراء العمليات في
الضفه يقول العاروري واخرون ان المرحله
الحاليه في الضفه الغربيه مختلفه تماما عم
ا جرى عليه الامر في السنوات الماضيه
نعود الى ضيفنا ساري اعراب الكاتب الواحد
السياسي يعني تقرير تطرق بتفصيل للتغيرات
التي
شهدها العمل الفصائل او المشهد الاشتباكات
دعنا نقول هذه التغييرات والتطورات كيف
يمكننا ان نفهمها
يعني هو في الحقيقه لا شك ان بنيه فصائل
المقاومه في الضفه الغربيه تعرضت الى
اضرار كبيره جدا منذ نهايه انتفاضه الاقصى
وعمليه سور الواقف العام 2002 واستمرار
اقتحامات
قلب المدن الفلسطينيه منذ ذلك التاريخ هذا
الامر بالتاكيد انهك الفصائل الفلسطينيه
ولا سيما وفصائل المقاومه التي القت صفها
الاول وكادرها الاساسي في اتون الانتفاضه
الفلسطينيه الثاني بالاضافه طبعا الى اثار
ما يسمى بالانقسام الفلسطيني على بنا
فصائل المقاومه الفلسطينيه في الضفه
الغربيه لكن هذا لا يعني ان فصائل
المقاومه كانت غائبه عن ساحه الضفه
الغربيه وعن المحاولات لا شك ان مشهديه
المقاومه في الضفه الغربيه متاثره الى حد
كبير ومستلهمه للتجربه المقاومه داخل قطاع
غزه والتي هي التجربه تنظيميه بامتياز
كذلك كان هناك العديد من الشهداء الذين
ينتمون لفصائل المقاومه الفلسطينيه منذ
عام 2014 وحتى هذه اللحظه الذين نفذوا
عمليات نوعيه وهذه العمليات بالتاكيد خلقت
حاله من المحاكاه ومثلت حاله من الالهام
للعديد من الكوادر الفلسطينيه كذلك
العمليات التي تسمى عمليات فرديه نفذتها
العديد ممن ينت لفصائل فلسطينيه سواء كان
ذلك بدفع من تلك الفصائل او تعبئه من تلك
الفصائل امكان بمبادرات ذاتيه صرفه طبعا
بالنظر الى كل هذه الاعتبارات بالنظر الى
ممارسات الاحتلال وبالنظر الى انتفاش
ميليشيات المستوطنين وبالنظر الى
الاعتداءات المتكرره على المسجد الاقصى
وبالنظر الى محاولات اذلال الفلسطينيين
داخل ساحه الضفه الغربيه من خلال تقييد
حركه الفلسطينيين بل وتعطيش الفلسطينيين
ايضا في الضفه الغربيه مع انعدام اي افق
لاي مشروع تسويه في الحاله الفلسطينيه
لابد ان ذلك كله سوف يثمر مثل هذه الحاله
التي نشاهدها الان هذا الى اي مدى يشكل
تحديا
للاسرائيليين هذه التطورات والتغييرات
التي جئنا على ذ
هذا تحدي كبير جدا بالنسبه للمنظومه
الاسرائيليه كلها بكل مستوياتها على
المستوى السياسي والمستوى الامني والمستوى
العسكري لا شك ان المؤسسه الاسرائيليه
مرتبكه الى حد كبير ازاء حاله المقاومه
الموجوده في الضفه الغربيه الجيش
الاسرائيلي للعدد الاكبر من تشكيلات
ووحدات الجيش الاسرائيلي هي منبثه داخل
ساحه الضفه الغربيه التي تمثل اليوم
الساحه المركزيه في مقاومه وفي مواجهه
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي كذلك سياسات الاحتلال
معقده في مواجهه هذه الحاله يعني بمعنى
وربما جرت الاشاره في احدى التقارير
السابقه التي بثتها قناه الجزيره ان توسيع
الهجمه الامنيه والعسكريه على الضفه
الغربيه من شانه ان يشرك قطاعات اوسع
وشرائح اكثر من الجماهير الفلسطينيه
واشعار شرائح اوسع من الجماهير الفلسطينيه
بالحاله الكفاحيه والنضاليه الموجوده في
الضفه الغربيه وبالتالي الاحتلال محتار
ومتردد ازاء الاجراءات هل يعتمد الاجراءات
الجزئيه الموضعيه التي تقوم على اغتيالات
محدوده واعتقالات محدوده مع مراهنه على
الزمن وامكانيه تفكيك هذه الحاله مع الزمن
الذي ربما تعتقد اوساط من الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي انه لصالح الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
مثلا ام يشن حملات اوسع ويخشى ان يسبق
الزمن الاحتلال الاسرائيلي لكن من شان هذه
الحملات ان تشرك قطاعات وشرائح اوسع يعني
فلسطينيين في حاله المقاومه القائمه شكرا
جزيلا من رام الله ساري عرابي الكاتب
والباحث السياسي
[موسيقى]
في زياره هي الاولى له الى جنوب السودان
والثانيه له الى خارج البلاد منذ اندلاع
القتال عقد رئيس مجلس السياده السودانيه
عبد الفتاح البرهان مباحثات مع رئيس دوله
جنوب السودان
في العاصمه في هذه الاثناء قال يوسف
ابراهيم عزت مستشار قوات الدعم السريع انه
ناقش في اديس ابابا مع موسى فقي رئيس
مفوضيه الاتحاد الافريقي التطورات الراهنه
في السودان وسبل الوصول الى الحل الشامل
لقاء لقاء وصفته الخارجيه السودانيه
بالسابقه الخطيره
بتوقيت الحرب هي الثانيه
ثانيه رحلات الفريق اول عبد الفتاح
البرهان الخارجيه تقوده الى جوبا لا يغيب
مسار العلاقات الثنائيه عن لقاء رئيس مجلس
السياده السوداني مع رئيس دوله جنوب
السودان سيلفاكير ميارديت غير ان الصراع
السودانيه المستفحله منذ اكثر من اربعه
شهور يفرض نفسه على الاجنده
نعتبر ان من مصلحتنا ايجاد حلول للمشاكل
في القاره وبالمنطقه وكما تعرفون الرئيس
الفاكر هو الشخص الاكثر قدره على حل
الازمه في السودان لمعرفته وعلاقته
الوطيده باهل هذا البلد كل الاعتبارات
تقول انه قادر اكثر من غيره على ايجاد حل
لهذه الازمه
الحلول الممكنه كان البرهان قد استعرضها
الاسبوع الماضي في مصر مع رئيسها عبد
الفتاح السيسي وكان ذلك تحركه الاقليميه
الاول منذ خروجه من الخرطوم بل منذ اندلاع
القتال بين الجيش الذي هو قائده وقوات
الدعم السريع غير ان مقدم البرهان الان
الى جوبا قد يعنى ببعض تفاصيل المشهد اذ
سبقه لقاؤه الاحد في بورتسودان بحاكم
اقليم دارفور مني اركو من ناوي الذي شدد
على ضروره تنفيذ اتفاق جوبا لضمان استدامه
السلام
والسلام يستعجل السودانيون الان حلوله في
عموم البلد
وبينما تتراجع الاحاديث عن الجهود
الدبلوماسيه والمبادرات لانهاء النزاع
يعمل طرفه كما يبدو على حشد الدعم كل
لمقاربته
رئيس مفوضيه الاتحاد الافريقي موسى فكي
التقى مستشار قائد قوات الدعم السريع في
مقر الاتحاد في الدس اباباه لكن سريعا صدر
بيان الخارجيه السودانيه الذي استنكر
اللقاء وصفه بالسابقه الخطيره
يقول البيان ان اللقاء يمنح الحركات
المعارضه المسلحه شرعيه لا تستحقها ويشكل
مخالفه واضحه لنظم واعراف المنظمه وكل
المنظمات الدوليه
تحذر الخارجيه السودانيه من ان رئيس
مفوضيه الاتحاد الافريقي يتمادى في
التعامل مع ميليشيا ترتكب فضائح ضد
المدنيين والنساء والاطفال على حد وصف
البيان
بعيدا عن البيانات تحتدم الاشتباكات في
الخرطوم التي تحولت الى ساحه معركه وليس
الوضع باقل التهابا في اقليم دارفور بغربي
البلاد حيث ياخذ القتال مسارات مختلفه
تماما مثل ما تختلف مسارات الفارين نزوحا
او لجوءا من مناطق القتال
المفوضيه الامميه الساميه لشؤون اللاجئين
اطلقت نداء لجمع مليار دولار للاسهام في
توفير مساعدات لمن انتهت رحلتهم في دول
جوار السودان يقول هؤلاء انهم في امس
الحاجه للمواد الغذائيه والخيام وتلك حاجه
تزداد مع بدء موسم الخريف بما يجلبه في
الغالب من عواصفه وامطار
في هذه الاثناء قال محمد حمدان حماطي قائد
قوات الدعم السريع في تسجيل صوتي في حسابه
في اكس او تويتر سابقا قال ان البرهان رفض
مقترحه بالتوامه بين قوات الدعم السريع
والجيش واضاف ان الجيش هو الذي بادر
بمهاجمه قواته وقال ان البرهان وعد واخلف
الوعد لانه خطط للانقلاب حسب تعبيره
احنا ما بدانا الحرب
انت هاجمتنا في محلاتنا وانا قبل عشره يوم
قعدت معاك وقدام شهود في مزرعه معاويه
البريط واتفقنا واتفقنا انه يا اخي
واتفقنا وانا حتى اقترحت لك قلت لك انا
اعمل توام الجيش الدعم السريع توامه بين
الجيش الدعم السليم
ونخنقت كده وبعدها وافقتها وكلمتك قلت لك
يا اخي
ده المفروض ما اقول كلام قلت لك قلت لك
طيران وفيها طيران اجنبي
ما رفضته انا بقول لك انا داري البديل لكن
انت ما رفدتها طيب انت قلت
هذا وتستعد ولايه البحر الاحمر لانشاء مقر
دائم لوزاره الخارجيه السودانيه ومقرات
رئاسيه ومركز مؤتمرات ومحطه لتحليه المياه
تستضيف ولايه البحر الاحمر مقرا مؤقتا
الان للخارجيه ومباني لامانه الحكومه ومن
ضمن اندلاع المواجهات في الخرطوم انتقلت
مؤسسات واجهزه الدوله والبعثات
الدبلوماسيه ومنظمات الامم المتحده
ومنظمات غير حكوميه حسب بيان لوكيل وزاره
الخارجيه السوداني الى ولايه البحر الاحمر
في الاستوديو ينضم الينا الدكتور اسامه
عيدروس الاكاديمي السوداني المتخصص في
الشؤون العسكريه السياسيه الشؤون السياسيه
والعسكريه اهلا وسهلا بك دكتور نبدا من
هذه النقطه انه في مقرات حتكون الخارجيه
والرئاسه في بورسودان والذي يعنيه ذلك
هو ما يعنيه حقيقه ليس المكان لكن يعني
انه فعلا الحكومه
انتبهت لغياب الاداره المدنيه لهذه الحرب
هذه الحرب عانه منها السودانيين مرتين
المعاناه المباشره من الحرب التي تسببت في
النزوح واللجوء بالاضافه الى غياب الحكومه
تم غياب اي اجهزه تنفيذيه عامله رغم انه
الحرب يعني موجوده في اماكن وكثير من
ولايات السودان لم تكن فيها ليس مؤشرا على
ان الحرب قد تطول كثيرا يعني يصبح الامر
اشبه يحدث في عدن على سبيل المثال وهو لا
بد من وضع كل الاحتياطات يعني لا يمكن هذه
دوله وهذه حياتنا ناس لا يمكن ان تترك
لتقديرات قد تصيبه قد تخطي مهما كانت
الاستعدادات العسكريه مع تعليقا على ما
سمعناه في تسجيل الصوتي لقائد الدعم
السريع اليوم
انا انتبهت فقط لشيء واحد يعني خلال هذه
هو الحديث يعني ايا كان هذا التسجيل هو
حقيقي غير حقيقي لا تم كثيرا بهذه الامر
لكن هي رساله من الدعم السريع من قوات
الدعم السريع المتمرده الى الشعب السوداني
في النهايه في هذه الرساله هنالك جزئيه
تتحدث عن انهم جاهزون ويعني بالتعبير
الدارج السوداني موشركين اي انهم كانمنون
للجيش في ام درمان وفي بحري وفي الخرطوم
قبل فتره انا تحدثت عن ان الدعم السريع
تحول الى الدفاع داخل الخرطوم وجهز نفسه
لهجمات قادمه من الجيش حقيقه رغم انه ايضا
يقوم ببعض الهجمات الان لكن هي هجمات
مربوطه بدعم خارجي ياتي من خارج الخرطوم
فتتم هجمه على معسكر الفريق البرهان ذهب
الى زياره الى جوبا قبل ذهب الى مصر هل
هذا محاوله
عن عن حل وهل الزيارتان مرتبطان
في ظني هنالك اختلاف في زيارتين مصر
باعتبارها داعم سياسي للدوله السودانيه
وكذلك داعم يعني قد يكون ايضا داعم عسكري
للجيش السوداني في حرب هذه لكن جنوب
السودان اظن الخصوصيه حول محاولات الدعم
السريع وحركه عبد العزيز الحلو لنقل الحرب
الى جنوب كردفان ربما هذا هو الملف الاهم
الذي زياره البرهان في وفد للدعم السريع
التقى مسؤولين في الاتحاد الافريقي
الخارجيه السودانيه اعتبرت ذلك سابقه
خطيره ولكن هناك من يقول تم يعني هم
يلتقون اصلا بمسؤولين في في جده في
السعوديه مسؤولين سعوديين ومسؤولين
امريكيين لماذا لا يلتقون بمسؤولين
الافريقي
الدوله لها سياده الذهاب الى مفاوضات في
جده بموافقه الدوله السودانيه وذابت وجلست
مع اخر يعني الدوله السعوديه لا تستقبل
المتمردين
كمبعوثين او حاملي رساله الى القياده
السعوديه من يستقبلوا هم وفد التفاوض في
جلسه مفاوضات الزياره الى الاتحاد
الافريقي مختلفه يعني الاتحاد الافريقي
مواقف غريبه جدا منذ بدايه هذه الازمه
يعني وصلت الى المناداه
بعاصمه خاليه منزوعه السلاح وقف الطيران
تدخل في السياده السودانيه بشكل يشري وكان
الدوله السودانيه غير موجوده شكرا الدكتور
اسامه السوداني المتخصص في الشؤون
السياسيه والعسكريه شكرا جزيلا
ادى رئيس اللجنه العسكريه الحاكمه في
الجابون الجنرال
رئيسا انتقال البلاد وقال في كلمه له ان
لجنه المرحله الانتقاليه بدات مشاوراتها
مع كل مؤسسات البلاد واكد ان جيم التزامه
ببذل كل الجهود لتكون لدى الجابون مؤسسات
قويه بنهايه المرحله الانتقاليه واضاف ان
السلطه ستسلم للمدنيين من خلال انتخابات
حره بنهايه المرحله الانتقاليه دون ان
يحدد مهله تلك المرحله هذا وقررت المجموعه
الاقتصاديه لدول وسط افريقيا
تعليق عضويه الجابون لحين عوده النظام
الدستوري
[موسيقى]
بات للبلاد رئيس جديد قائد الحرس الجمهوري
قبل اسبوع رئيس اللجنه الانتقاليه واعاده
المؤسسات قبل ايام الجنرال
الذي غدا رئيسا انتقاليه للغابون في اول
خطاب له بعد ادائه اليمين الدستوريه حاول
طمانه الجميع قال ان احلام الاجداد
السعيده توشك ان تصبح حقيقه ووعد سجناء
الراي والمنفيينه في فرج قريب
اتعهد رسميا بالاتخر جهدا من اجل ان يكون
لدى بلدنا الغابون مؤسسات دستوريه قويه
وديمقراطيه وذات مصداقيه بنهايه هذه
المرحله الانتقاليه اللجنه المكلفه
بالاعداد المرحله الانتقاليه بدات
مشاورتها مع كل القوى الحيه في المجتمع
وسيكون هناك عفوا عام عن السجناء
السياسيين
وسيتمكن كل المنفيين من العوده الى بلدهم
[موسيقى]
خارج القصر رقص انصار الانقلاب فرحا
بالنسبه اليهم بدايه عهد جيما هي نهايه
عهد حكم بنجو الاب والابن وود لطموح
الحفيد فقد وعدم الرئيس الجديد بالتغيير
وهو ما كانوا يتعطشون اليه لعقود
مع الرئيس نجيمه الجابون ستمضي قدما وكل
الاخطاء التي ارتكبت في الماضي بسبب
الاداره الكارثيه للشان العام ستتغير
اثق فيه ثقه كامله حقا ان انجز هذا
الانتقال ووضع الشخص المناسب في المكان
المناسب فسنكون سعداء للغايه
بتنصيب
رئيسا انتقاليا تكون الجابون قد طوت صفحه
علي بنجو وبدات عهدا جديدا لكن الى متى
سيستمر فقد غاب الحديث عن مده الفتره
الانتقاليه وهو ما يزيد منها واجلس
المعارضه التي تخشى ان تعوض ديكتاتوريه
مدنيه باخرى عسكريه تجد المعارضه
الجابونيه نفسها في وضع صعب فالشارع سعيد
بما يجري وما يحدث لا يخدمها يصير مرشحها
البير اند اوسا على انه الفائز في
الانتخابات التي اطيح بسبب نتائجها الرئيس
السابق علي بن غو لكن حلفائه في المعارضه
سارعوا الى لقاء الرئيس الجديد في مؤشر
على انه اصبح معزولا
منصه التناوب 23 التي تدعمه التقت الرئيس
اكثر من مره وراينا خلال حفل التنصيب ان
قاده التحالف حضروا التنصيب باستثناء اوسا
واعتقد انه خلال ايام سيكون مجبرا على
التصادم مع النظام العسكري
صدام لا يملك فيه مرشح المعارضه اي اوراق
قوه فقد حرص الرئيس الجديد على حضور
استعراض عسكري عقب تنصيبه لم تغب عنه
تشكيلات القوات المسلحه كافه فيما يشبه
حفله تقديم الولاء في رساله مفادها كل شيء
تحت السيطره
الينا الدكتور حسن كنانجي مدير معهد هورن
الدولي للدراسات الاستراتيجيه اهلا وسهلا
بك هذا الوعد من رئيس السلطه الانتقاليه
الذي اقسم اليمين الدستوريه الى اي مدى
يمكن ان يتمتع بمصداقيه في الجابون بانه
سيسلم لسلطه مدنيه ام تراه ان يرتدي بدله
مدنيه ويصبح هو الرئيس
بمجرد تغيير الديكور انجاز التعبير
حقيقه
الرئيس لم يحدد مده المده الانتقاليه وهذا
يعني انه يترك الامور لايه احتمالات وربما
قد في النهايه
يحاول تمديد مده حكمه الان لا توجد ايه
مقاومه لمثل هذه
هذا النمط من الحكم لان الشعب الجابوني
طيله مرحله الاستقلال لم يعرف سوى رئيسين
من نفس العائله ربما ما يقوله له شرعيه
لكن ربما سيحاول في ذات الوقت تعزيز قوته
مستقبلا هناك من يقول انه هو نفسه من نفس
العائله فهل يمكن القول انه استمرار لحكم
عائله
بونجو في هذه الحاله
نعم ولا نعم لانه في الحقيقه هو جزء من
العائله الممتده لكن
في اي نظام يكون فيه الرئيس او العائله
تحكم لاكثر من خمسين عاما يكون تقريبا من
المستحيل ان تاتي بشخص من خارج هذه
المنظومه لان
المنسوبيه التي والمحسوبيه التي يقومون
بها يعني تغلغل من هم معهم في الاجهزه
العسكريه والامنيه وكافه اذرع الدوله لهذا
السبب ليس من قبيل المفاجاه ان الجنرال
انجاما هو من نفس العائله لكن ايضا يجب ان
نقول ان البلد يحتاج الى اتجاه جديد وهو
حاليا يحظى بدعم شعبي كونه الجابون او ما
حدث فيها من انقلاب بعيد عن التجاذبات
الاقليميه مختلف تماما الامر والتفاعل
الاقليمي والدولي مع ما حدث في النيجر هل
هذا يوجد مناخا التوصل الى حل اسهل فيه هل
هذا يسهل عمليه التوصل الى حل في الجابون
الانقلاب حدث في الغابون في ظروف مختلفه
الجابون بلد عدد سكانه صغير لكنه بلد صريح
ايضا لهذا السبب من حيث
العوامل الخارجيه
وتدخلهم طبعا يؤيدون الاستقرار في البلد
مقارنه بالانقلابات التي رايناها في غرب
افريقيا وفي الساحل في الغابون الوضع اقل
اثاره للجدل ورغم الادانات من على مستوى
الاقليم والمستوى العالمي البلد فيه موارد
يمكن ان يديم نفسه الى فتره تتجاوز الوضع
سنوات الاولى بعد الانقلاب شكرا لك
الدكتور حسن كاننجي مدير معهد هورن الدولي
لدراسات الاستراتيجيه حدثنا من نيروبي في
كينيا
انقلاب الجابون كان واحدا من اكثر من 200
محاوله انقلابيه شهدتها القاره منذ منتصف
القرن الماضي لم تنجح كلها لكنها باتت
هاجسا بكثير من الدول في افريقيا هذا
الموضوع سنناقشه في فقره في المتابعه بعد
قليل
[موسيقى]
قال الرئيس الروسي بلاديمير بوتين انه
بمجرد رفع العقوبات الغربيه عن نقل الحبوب
والاسمده الروسيه ستعود موسكو الى صفقه
الحبوب واضاف في مؤتمر صحفي مع الرئيس
التركي رجب طيب اردوغان عقب محادثاتهما في
سوتشي ان الغرب خدع روسيا بشان الاهداف
الانسانيه لمبادره البحر الاسود وان موسكو
اجبرت على الخروج من الاتفاقيه لان الدول
الغربيه فرضت عقوبات عليها من جانبه قال
الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان انه يعتقد
انه سيجري الاتفاق على حل بشان مبادره
الحبوب وقال اردوغان ان دوله قطر بالفعل
تقدم المساعي والمساعدات الماليه والتمويل
بشكل خاص لنقل الحبوب للدول الافريقيه
وقال بوتين ان مبادره البحر الاسود ليست
بديلا للمسار التركيه القطري بشان يسار
الحبوب للدول المحتاجه بل هي اليه اضافيه
واكد ان العمل جار على توريد مليون طن من
الحبوب الى تركيا بمساعده قطريه لدعم
الدولي الاكثر فقرا
نعتزم تنظيم توريد مليون طن من الحبوب من
روسيا الى تركيا بسعر تفضيلي للمعالجه ثم
النقل المجانيه الى الدول الاكثر فقرا
نعول ايضا على مساعده دوله قطر المستعده
لدواعي انسانيه لدعم الدول الاكثر فقرا
نحن على وشك ابرام اتفاقيات مع ست دول
افريقيه حيث نعتزم توفير الغذاء مجانا
وتنفيذ الخدمات اللوجستيه مجانا لتسليم
هذه الشحنه المفاوضات تقترب من الاكتمال
تقريبا وستبدا عمليات التسليم خلال
الاسبوعين المقبلين
من جانبه قال الرئيس التركي رجب طيب
اردوغان انه من المهم العمل على نموذج
دائم لاستمرار مبادره البحر الاسود لتصدير
الحبوب وايجاد حزمه جديده للاتفاق عليها
مع روسيا والامم المتحده واضاف ان تركيا
تعمل لانجاز هذه الحزمه الجديده خلال فتره
قصيره
ايام الاخيره سعينا لانعاش اتفاقيه الحبوب
تلعب مبادره البحر الاسود دورا خاصا في
مساعده الدول الفقيره وهي مهمه جدا لها
والان من الضروري ايجاد حزمه جديده
للاتفاق عليها مع الجانب الروسي والامم
المتحده ونحن في تركيا سنعمل خلال فتره
وجيزه لوضع حل مناسب لهذه الاتفاقيه
وفي اول تعليق على لقاء القمه بين بوتين
واردوغان والذي جرى خلاله بحث اتفاق تصدير
الحبوب من اوكرانيا قال وزير الخارجيه
الاوكرانيه دي متروكوليبا ان استئناف
العمل بالاتفاق يجب الا ياتي نتيجه ما
سماه الابتزاز الروسي واعتبر الوزير ان
الجانب الروسي لا يمكن الوثوق به وبالتالي
يتعين البحث عن بدائل حسب تعبيره وكشف
كوليبا ان اردوغان بعد لقائه بوتين سيلتقي
الرئيس الاوكراني
في غضون ذلك قالت القوات الجويه
الاوكرانيه ان دفاعاتها اعترضت 23 طائره
مسيره من اصل سنتين من اصل اثنتين استهدفت
المناطق الجنوبيه والشرقيه للبلاد وقال
مسؤولون اوكرانيون ان روسيا شنت هجوما
جويا ليله الماضيه على احد الموانئ
الرئيسيه لتصدير الحبوب في اوديسا وافاد
مراسل الجزيره ان الدفاعات الجويه
الاوكرانيه اعترضت سبعه عشره طائره روسيه
مسيره كانت تحاول مهاجمه موانئ اوديسا من
جهته قال حاكم اوديسا ان الهجوم اسفر عن
تدمير مخازن للحبوب ومنشات الانتاجيه في
ميناء اسماعيل وهو احد المينائين
الرئيسيين لتصدير الحبوب على نهر الدانوب
وزير الدفاع الروسيه وقال ان اوكرانيا
اوكرانيا تستغل موانئها في البحر الاسود
لتصنيع المسيرات وشن هجمات على البنيه
التحتيه الروسيه واكد شويجو ان القوات
الروسيه ستواصل استهداف هذه المنشات
المبادره التي تقدمت بها دوله قطر وتركيا
لضمان تامين وصول الحبوب الى الدول الاكثر
فقرا في العالم تنص على تصدير القمح
الروسي الى تركيا لتتولى بدورها ارساله
الى الدول الفقيره بتمويل من قطر وهي
تتزامن مع جهود دبلوماسيه لاعاده استئناف
العمل بمبادره البحر الاسود للحبوب والتي
انسحبت منها روسيا
[موسيقى]
فارقا في حرب على اوكرانيا ليس ميدانيا
التطور تمثل بالتوقيع على ما سمي اتفاق
البحر الاسود او اتفاقيه اسطنبول
اهميتها تكمن في انها سمحت باعاده تصدير
الحبوب الاوكرانيه والتقليل من حده ازمه
الغذاء العالميه كما اتاحت لروسيا تصدير
منتجات زراعيه واسمده رغم العقوبات عليها
علقت روسيا العمل بالاتفاقيه في شتاء
العام نفسه
تذرعت انذاك باستهداف مقر اسطول البحر
الاسود في سيفاستوبل وبعد تدخل دبلوماسي
تركي استانف الاتفاق وبعد اقل من عام
انسحبت موسكو منه بشكل كلي
في مقابل ذلك وتحت وطئه ازمه غذاء عالميه
بدات تتجدد قررت اوكرانيا اعتمادا مسارات
بديله لتصدير حبوبها باعتماد ميناء اوداسا
وموانئ على نهر الدانوب تقول روسيا ان
الامم المتحده والغرب تجاهل شرطا مهما في
صفقه الحبوب وهو استئناف تصدير الامونيا
الروسيه عبر انبوب طوليات اوديسا والذي
فجر داخل الاراضي الاوكرانيه
وايضا تعاني روسيا تقطع تصدير منتجاتها
الزراعيه بشكل سلس حسب ما تقول وتتهم
روسيا الامم المتحده بالتغاضي عما تصفها
بالهجمات الارهابيه والاعمال التخريبيه
الاوكرانيه كاستهداف جسر القرم
وتعتبر موسكو ان الامم المتحده فشلت في
تطبيق احد بنود الاتفاق الذي ينص على
اعاده ادماج البصل في الزراعي الروسي
بنظام سويفت للتعاملات المصرفيه الخاصه
باتفاق الحبوب
اوكرانيا عدت حينها انسحاب روسيا من
الاتفاقيه بانها خطه مسبقه تهدف من خلالها
موسكو الى حصار الموانئ والهيمنه على
البحر الاسود ثم احتكار سوق الحبوب
العالمي بالهيمنه على اسواق التصدير
الاوكرانيه قصرا ومنذ الانسحاب الروسي
نشطت اكثر من دوله على الصعيد الدبلوماسي
لايجاد حلول تفاديا لازمه غذاء جديده
فكانت مبادره قطريه تركيه تنص على ان تغطي
الدوحه ثمن كميات كبيره من القمح تصل الى
مليون طن ترسل الى البلدان الاكثر حاجه
بالتزامن مع محاوله تركيا احياء اتفاق
اسطنبول لتصدير الحبوب الاوكرانيه
لكن كما يبدو فان موسكو لا ترى تعارضا بين
استئناف مبادره الحبوب والعمل بالمبادره
القطريه
فبينما كان يؤمل ان يعلن الرئيس التركي
رجب طيب اردوغان استعاده الاتفاق في
اجتماعه مع نظيره الروسي فلاديمير بوتين
في سوتشي فقد افضل اجتماع الى مزيد من
التشاور كما يبدو من كلمتي كوتن واردوغان
معنى من باريس الدكتور زياد ماجد والساده
العلوم السياسيه في الجامعه الامريكيه في
باريس دكتور لماذا لم يتم يعني احداث
اختراق في موضوع الحبوب هذا مع روسيا
اظن ان السبب الرئيسي هو الشروط الروسيه
الان موسكو تدرك ان لديها ورقه تفوضيه
مهمه ترتبط بالامن الغذائي العالمي وترتبط
باحتمالات ارتفاع اسعار القمح والحبوب
عشيه الخريف ومن ثم طبعا الشتاء وهذا امر
يمكن ان توظفه في سياق مفاوضات هي تريد
كما ذكر تقريركم بشكل خاص ان يعاد دمج
مصرفها الزراعي في نظام سويفت وهو مع يقول
عنه الامريكيون والاوروبيون انه تحايل على
عقوبات نظام سويفت او اخراج روسيا من
النظام المصري في العالمي واعتقد ان دون
هذا الشرط مساله القبول بتصدير روسيا
لحبوب لمنتجات ومواد زراعيه اخرى اظن ان
تركيا تملك القدره للقبول بذلك باسم
المجتمع الدولي لان الامم المتحده طرف طرف
عفوا في هذا
لكن مساله السويفت والبنك الزراعي اظنها
حتى الان خارج اطار البحث ولذلك كل طرف
ينتظر ان يتنازل الطرف الاخر بشكل اضافي
عن مطالبه وشروطه طبعا كل طرف يتهم الاخر
ولكن الى اي مدى موضوع الحبوب هذا يخضع
لما يوصف بالابتزاز السياسي
والاستخدام كورقه في هذه الحرب
هو منذ البدايه يستخدم كورقه ترتبط بموضوع
البحر الاحمر ترتبط ايضا ببحر ازوف الذي
اصبح شبه بحيره روسيه بعد ضم جزيره القرن
البحر الاسود والموقع التركي البحر الاسود
نعم وبحر ازوف داخله اصبح بالتالي موضوع
تصدير القمح والحبوب من البحر الاسود الى
البحر المتوسط موضوع حيوي لروسيا
ولاوكرانيا وطبعا تركيا لديها الميزه
التفاضليه العليا بسبب البوسفور والدردنيل
ويريد الرئيس الروسي بعد ان استعاد حضوره
الاساسي في حلف شمالي الاطلسي وبعد ان لعب
دورا يدعم فيه اوكرانيا بالسلاح ولكن يبقي
التفاوض مع موسكو قائما ويبقي علاقات جيده
مع بوتين يريد ايضا من جهته قبل انعقاد
اجتماع الامم المتحده ان يحصل على وعود
روسيه على الاقل
تصدير القمح وارساله عبر تركيا طبعا في
الاثناء الاحاديث عن تصدير القمح او
الحبوب للدول الاكثر فقرا وبوتين يقول ان
ما يفعله لا يتعارض ايضا مع ما تفعله
تركيا وقطر الى اي مدى هذا يمكن ان يمنع
بالفعل كارثه عالميه
طبعا مهم جدا ان تصل الحبوب والقمح الى
عدد من الدول الافريقيه التي تعاني جفافا
تحتاج لذلك ليس فقط لانتاج بعض السلع
الغذائيه وانما ليعيش ملايين البشر
وبالتالي
لنصل الى هذه النقطه يكون هناك تقدم اساسي
قد حصل روسيا تريد تبييض صفحتها من خلال
هذا الاتفاق تركيا وقطر تلعبان دورا
اساسيا في تطبيقه ويمكن على الاقل بمرحله
مؤقته اذا نجح هذا الامر ان يكون مقدمه
لنجاح اضافي ربما نكون امام مسار تدريجي
كل فتره يتم الافراج فيها عن كميه معينه
شكرا يتم تصدير كميه معينه الى ان يعاد
العمل باتفاق النهائي شكرا جزيلا من باريس
الدكتور زياد ماجد والساده الاعلام
السياسيه في الجامعه الامريكيه في باريس
في سوريا قالت مصادر ومحليه للجزيره ان
مقاتلي العشائر العربيه استعادوا السيطره
على مدينه الشحيل في دير الزور الشرقي وصد
هجوما لما تعرف بقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه
على بلدتي ذبيان والحوائج كما اكدت مصادر
محليه ان مقاتلي العشائر العربيه جددوا
هجومهم على محاور القتال في محيط مدينه
منبج في حلب ضد ما تعرف بقوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه وذلك دعما لقوات العشائر في
ريف دير الزور شرقيه الفرات
المستمره وتبادل للسيطره في مواقع تشهد
اشتباكات بين قوات العشائر والوحدات
الكرديه في وقت تسيطر فيه قوات العشائر
على المنطقه المحاديه لنهر الفرات من
الضفه الشرقيه الممتده من منطقه هجين على
الحدود العراقيه حتى البصيره الواقعه في
عمق محافظه دير الزور
المعارك التي بدات منذ ايام كانت منحصره
بمجلس دير الزور العسكري مواجهه الوحدات
الكرديه تحول الى مواجهه ما تعرف بقوات
سوريا الديمقراطيه مع العشائر العربيه
التي تطالب باداره مستقله لمناطق يشكلون
فيها المكون الوحيد
في حين وصفت ما تعرف بقوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه مقاتلي العشائر بالمخربين
المدفوعين من النظام السوري وايران
التطورات في دير الزور وجدت صداها لدى
مقاتلي العشائر بريف حلبه وادلب حيث شنوا
هجوما من عده محاور باتجاه مدينه منبج
وسيطروا ايضا على ريف تلتمر بمنطقه راس
العين في محافظه الحسكه
فيما هنا اشراف لبعض شيوخ العشائر على سير
المعارك
هذا الرباط تقريبا ما يمكن مسافه
اثنين ثلاثه كيلو متر عن المنطقه هذه
والله العظيم اللي بيه دم وبين خوى من
هالناس
يقدم الهناس هيا اللي قاعد تمشي مشان
تحرير المنطقه من هيل حتى دير الزور هذه
الخيام يطلق عليها اسم ديوان الحرب
وانتشارها شماليه سوريا يشير الى توسع
رقعه المواجهات
ولن تزال الا بعد تحقيق الغايه التي اقيمت
من اجلها
نظام ما يسمى الفزعه لدى العشائر دعا لحشد
مقاتلين جدد واتخاذ العده لفتح مزيد من
محاور القتال نحن باسم القبائل والعشائر
متجهين بعون الله الى نثبت اخوتنا بدير
الزور
وتجانا ان شاء الله وتعالى
ان شاء الله قادمون
ويشيروا تزايد اعداد الملتحقين بجبهات
القتال من ابناء العشائر الى اصرار هذه
القبائل على المضي قدما حتى تحقيق كامل
اهدافهم عمر الحوراني الجزيره من شمالي
سوريا
بالعوده الى القاره الافريقيه واجواء
الانقلابات حيث تسارع دول في القاره الى
اتخاذ تدابير استباقيه فسرت بانها تحسب
استباقي من انتقال عدوى الانقلابات ففي
الكاميرون اجرى الرئيس بول هي تغييرات
كبيره على مستوى وزاره الدفاع شمل التعيين
قاده الجدد للقوات المسلحه وسلاح الجو
البحريه وقوات الدرك وتخشى السلطات هناك
من تكرار سيناريو جارتها الجنوبيه الجابون
خاصه ان البلاد يحكمها منذ اكثر من اربعين
عاما الرئيس بيا البالغ حاليا من العمر 90
عاما وهو متهم بالفساد وتزوير الانتخابات
الرئاسيه الاخيره وعلى نفس المنوال وبعد
وقت قصير من انقلاب الجابون قرر الرئيس
الروندي
حاله عشرات من كبار الضباط على التقاعد
وتسريح مئات العسكريين من جنود وضباط صف
في رواندا ويحكم كاميراندا منذ عام 2000
وهو يتطلع الى البقاء في السلطه حتى عام
2034 بعد تعديل الدستور في عام 2015
وفي سيراليون اعتقلت السلطات مجموعه من
ضباط الجيش بتهمه التخطيط لتنفيذ انقلاب
عسكري بالتزامن مع احتجاجات شعبيه في
العاصمه
في الجابون على نتائج الانتخابات
المتنازعة عليها
الجيش على السلطه في الجابون والنيجر
سبقته عده انقلابات في افريقيا خلال
السنوات الثلاث الماضيه من ابرزها اطاحه
الجيش في بوركينا فاسو بالرئيس روكا بوري
في يناير من عام 2022 وفي نيسان عام 2021
تولى الجيش التشادي السلطه خلافا لما
يقتضيه دستور البلاد بعد مقتل الرئيس
ادريس ديبي وفي مالي اطاحت مجموعه من
العسكريين بالرئيس ابراهيم ابو بكر كيتا
في اغسطس عام 2020
ومنذ منتصف القرن العشرين شهدت افريقيا
اكثر من 200 محاوله انقلابيه نجحت نحو 38%
منها في الاطاحه بالسلطه القائمه خاصه في
وسط القاره وغربها
من ابو جاي ينضم الينا ديفيد اوتو اندلي
مدير مركز اجنيف للامن والدراسات
الاستراتيجيه في افريقيا اهلا وسهلا بك
يبدو ان هناك تحسبا لانقلابات اخرى كما
ذكرنا عده دول كانت فيها اجراءات لتغييرات
في القياده
العسكريه الى اي مدى يرجح ان تكون هناك
انقلابات اخرى في غرب وسط افريقيا تحديدا
في الفتره المقبله وحتى في الشرق كما
شاهدنا الاجراءات التي اتخذها الرئيس
الرواندي
على سبيل المثال
بان القضيه هي انه طالما يستمر هناك غياب
للعدل وعدم المساواه واستمرار الفساد
وقضايا عدم استطباب الامن وفساد اقتصادي
هو دائما سيجعل احتمال وقوع انقلاب عسكري
قائما لكن طبعا لا نعرف اي بلد سيكون
التالي لكن فقط من خلال تغيير القيادات
العسكريه لا يضمن ان الانقلابات لم تقع
لان بعض البلدان التي راينا فيها انقلابات
عسكريه قد وقعت سبق لها وان غيرت القيادات
العسكريه قبل وقت قريب من ذلك او يخططون
ذلك القضيه لا تتعلق بتغيير القيادات
العسكريه بل بالحوكمه الرشيده وبالاستجابه
لحاجاتي وتطلعاته الشعب لان اكبر عنصر في
اي انقلاب عسكري هو مد نعم الشعبي الذي
سيحظى به فطالما ان الشعب ليس راضيا من
الحكام احتمال وقوع انقلاب وارد وان يحظى
بتاييد الشعب وارد ايضا منذ 1950 كان هناك
200 انقلاب في افريقيا ولكن الفتره
الماضيه تحديدا الانقلابات تحدث في غرب
افريقيا ووسطها نتحدث في ثلاث سنوات عن
ثمانيه انقلابات لماذا في هذه المنطقه من
افريقيا بالذات
كما ذكرتم
اول مجموعه من الانقلابات التي وقعت في
افريقيا كانت بسبب ان النخب التي كانت
مسؤوله عن الكفاح من اجل الاستقلال جاءت
الى الحكم
وايضا لان لها الحق بعد ان كاف حتى
الاستعمار لكن هم احتاجوا طبعا الى دعم
الجيش
واستخدموا الجيش ايضا لكبح جماح اي حركه
احتجاجيه من الشعب لهذا السبب القيادات
العسكريه رات في نفسها بديلا افضل لان
اعتبرت ان هؤلاء الحكام المدنيين كانوا
ضعافا في بلدان الساحل تلك البلدان التي
ارادت نوع من الاستق
والديمقراطيه والتعايش مع البلدان الغربي
على اساس انها كانت دمى للانظمه الغربيه
تم ازاحتها من قبل المؤسسات عسكريه التي
كانت تحميهم لهذا السبب راينا من يقول
الان ان الديمقراطيه لا تنفع ولا تنجح لان
النظام الديمقراطي الذي يتم
لم يؤدي الى استقلال حقيقي لا في القضاء
ولا في الاقتصاد ولا في اي شيء جزيلا من
اوتو اندلي مدير مركز جنيف الامن
والدراسات الاستراتيجيه في افريقيا
بهذا نصل الى نهايه الحصاد الليله شكرا
وتصبحون على خير
[موسيقى]